il avait été mis en échec en la première
fois un casse tête
il voulait devenir l'élu et retirer
l'épée des légendes mais à la limite ce
qu'on peut faire c'est on peut combattre
en tapant l'ennemi comme ça loïc toi ça
serait comme un petit gourde a un goût
redis nous bienvenue dans excalibur
et puis je ne suit ou suite et fin le
hic on parie sur quoi ok moi je parie
contre moi aussi je peux partir une
suite dans les commentaires vous pouvez
me dire si vous pensez que je le finisse
coup-ci ou pas loïc en longitude disto
même généré oui
est ce que le générique est finie loïc
bien datant où c'est ça ok le générique
est donc finie donc bienvenu sur cette
chaîne youtube si vous connaissez pas je
m'appelle fabien olicard dans la vie je
fais plein de choses pas que des ce
casse tête mais je fais souvent des
castels depuis deux ans et demi trois
ans tout comme ça ils se glissent ligne
plus galérer à c'est pas le premier qui
me met en échec qui en avait eu 1 le 1er
janvier 2018 que j'avais réussi à finir
on avait passé 17 heures dessus
bon oui on n'est pas encore à 17 heures
mais on sent que ça va être compliqué
parce que l'autre j'avais trouvé des
patterns dans quelle méthodologie pour
le réseau de la gîte toujours pas trouvé
donc on ne sait pas si ça va être la
suite ou la suite et fin je dirais beau
commentaire à ce sujet évidemment on va
essayer de l'avancer dessus et
j'aimerais bien le finir aujourd'hui au
mois enlevé une pièce enlevée une pièce
le 1 2 euro
juste avant de commencer laissez moi
vous présenter ceci ça c'est mon
magazine curieuse le numéro 4 va sortir
il sera dans vos boîtes aux lettres le
15 juin
si vous n'êtes pas abonné vous pouvez
vous abonner dès aujourd'hui je mets un
lien dans la description pour ceux qui
sont déjà abonnés je vous réponds tout
de suite à une question vous allez vous
poser le magazine 3 sera livrée en même
temps que le 4 et les deux également
pour ceux qui en ont fait la demande
parce qu'avec le coc vide les imprimeurs
étaient fermés les routeurs aussi la
poste c'était compliqué donc vous
l'aviez eu en format numérique dans
votre espace mais curieuse et bien un
magazine papier qui arrive tous les mois
dans votre boîte aux lettres
quand on dit c'est parti c'est le jeu
part où aller on le reprend ah oui
c'était le fameux truc pour que je
puisse le baisser même si je ne sais pas
encore si un intérêt à le lbc ou pas
quoi ça c'était les postiches même plus
à quoi il servait mieux fait de le
marquer c'est dommage que je ne puisse
pas à le reprendre à zéro qui est touché
mais la prochaine fois à la ronde la
réponse est oui j ai touché et je pense
que si je le finis pas aujourd'hui géré
toucherait avant donc on fasse un vrai
tournage mais je filmerai peut-être avec
mon téléphone tant que laisser des
traces
en fait le jour même on l'a fait le soir
je lis un peu encore tripoter un petit
vraiment ça me prenait la tête de venir
mais on va s'en sortir comment de ce
truc clôture donc donc aussi garder les
pieds sont peut-être pas exactement
pareil parce que effectivement je je
continue à l'aller avec tripatouiller un
peu exactement ce que je fais là en fait
un mode ça a pas tellement de buts de
sens à la vie
ils le trouvent trop là les commentaires
j'ai pas pu sortir une vidéo
sentiez pas un millier de commentaires
sur est la suite d'excalibur séquence il
te plait basse et c'est quand on tourne
les vidéos mais en l'occurrence on avait
tourné des vidéos dont le loup garou
pendant le confinement et ben je
comptais bien les sortir quand même
avant un millier d'années cette pièce
elle est pas mal
donc j'ai une pièce qui fait un petit
peu as ou 1 2 plus tôt plus qu'un est
d'ailleurs qui fait 1 2 alors j'imagine
que ça c'est sur sa surface
longitudinale que je vois ça mais en
dessous elle doit être différente d'un
simple caisse parce que sinon je
pourrais je pourrais déjà le sortir je
sens aussi qu'il faut un peu forcé mais
j'ai peur de la casse et si tu vois ce
que je veux dire ça c'est un truc
marrant il ya une petite remontée des
ventes de casse têtes en france depuis
un an et demi je pense qu'en vrai j'ai
contribué à ça en en faisant mexique est
dans le c'est que personne n'a identifié
un jeu direct pas de partenariat
qu'athlète je reçois pas des casse-têtes
gratos des gones savent quoi dire si une
fois on en a reçu mais c'étaient des
classiques que cette hyper classique
d'asie qu'on connaît tous la roma 2
casse tête comme ça un peu style est en
fait ce qui m'agace un peu ce qu'ils
disent pas que ça m'agace c'est que ça
me stresse je me dis si je le pose comme
ça c'est pas mal aussi pour le film et
tu vois mais si jamais il faut descendre
excalibur et que ça fait partie de la
solution pas ce que veut dire la gravité
qu'amène un truc c'est compliqué quoi
alors tu sais quoi je te demanderai pas
d accélération loïc aujourd'hui je le
dis parce que battu les mettra bien
quand tu veux toi en fait mais par
contre s'il te plaît loïc c'est une
demande solennelle mais la belle musique
mais la bonne musique parce qu'après moi
faut que je m'explique en dm avec tout
le monde
donc s'il te plaît loïc dit lui dans les
commentaires qui met la bonne musique
s'il vous plaît je propose qu'on lance
dans les commentaires le mais la bonne
musique loïc peut-être après tu voudras
le faire un petit week
c'est vrai que ça faisait très alarme de
vieilles voitures
j'essaye toujours les moufles que je
peux faire une fois que j'ai fait j'ai
peur de faire une boucle de mou tu sais
quand vous voyez quand je vois les côtés
là je me dis aux débuts ici avec quatre
trucs au départ avec un creux donc gelé
tellement mixer le truc je ne sais même
pas qui était là et comment c'était
ouais cherche des excuses la femme est
un nom j'explique elle à quel point ce
complexe mais pas seulement cette passe
sa part au dessus la cheville et moi
comme des grands jeux ça aucun rapport
du coup depuis que j'ai appris que tu
étais libre et c'était pas gagné voilà
ce qu'ils comprennent pas c'est que vous
ne suivez pas sûr twitch le également
ses membres du privé d'eau que je
mettrais nos jeunes tout dans la
description autant vous raconter ça
voilà bon bah c'est une feinte de centre
grande difficulté c'est qu'on revient en
boucle j'aimerais bien quand même les
marquer définitivement tous cas ce matin
loïc pourquoi y appuie les versions
longues des casse tête
bon c'est pas tellement en fait personne
ne les regardaient vraiment et on a
perdu l'habitude de le faire jouer
ce qui n'empêche que sur la chaîne
secondaire on pose quand même des trucs
genre là la semaine dernière n'a posté
le best-of twitch quand on a fait la
toiture les ça s'est un peu retrouvée
noël j'ai trouvé une vague j'ai trouvé
une bonne alors ressemble à peine de
voir les plus forts comme le micro est
loin vous est pris ça comme habitudes
ont la vie ceux qui embarquent avec une
voix comme la voix journalistes au
détecteur ça j'aimerais s'il vous plaît
ce soir manger des pâtes la sauce est
prête encore de la bolognaise
qu'est ce que je fais je me dis ce
serait intéressant que je sache qui
communique avec qui au niveau des petits
en bout je cherche en fait à trouver une
méthodologie pour être moins
à l'aveuglette fabien post-it masters
c'est la caste des préférés de ta soeur
en plus il fait chaud là il commence à
faire chaud ici on va sentir sur les
bras d'ailleurs c'est pas la sueur qui
sent sous les bras loïc ce sens les
bactéries qui se nourrissent de ta sueur
d'accord qu'en fait tu sentais bactéries
merci dire que au final il n'y a que
huit pièces plus la pièce de l'épée quoi
enfin beaucoup
voilà ce que j'ai fait je vous raconte
je sais pas si ça me servira vraiment ou
pas mais donc j'ai repéré cet embout là
c'est celui ci là ça vous paraît vous
dit pas c'est évident mais pas forcément
évident par exemple que celui ci soit
relié avec ce petit bout là qui à la
houe et oui d'ailleurs avec toi tu
appartiens qui toi je m'appelle toujours
jean-michel bouts de bois et je
n'appartiens à personne je suis libre je
marche vers ma destinée vers le soleil
couchant et rien ni personne
jean michel jean michel vous revenez ici
non non ça suffit maintenant michel ces
derniers le générique vous ne me laissez
vous vous laissez tranquille oui vous
savez ce qu'il va se passer mais ça va
définir en cure nom en devenant maire
jean-michel non pas comme ma maman mais
j'aimerais bien le 2 décembre je sais
pas beaucoup aux premières qui se passe
ah ah ah la vache l'hésitation bien mais
en même temps je ne sais pas pourquoi je
suis fier de moi parce que j'ai remis en
place
excalibur il est de nouveau en place
simple mot on a fait une vidéo entière
et j'ai réussi à l'arrêt êtes un oui bah
en même temps tout à l'heure je fantasme
et 2 milliards basso bien d'en repartir
à zéro pour voir mais c'est si déceptif
de se dire jeu en faisant un clic taklha
j'ai tourné
j'avais donc tellement rien fait j'étais
tellement tourné en rond
[Musique]
à retenir les couleurs ça m'aide parce
que ça m'aide à me rappeler desquels des
calculs et quelques jets boujaer
[Musique]
bon alors ce montage il ya combien de
temps de russia a
je bouge l'e2c bouge les deux je peux
descendre lui maintenant on ne peut pas
le dessin ainsi a pu du coup lui les
retenu que par l'union si louis c'est
lui je le descends je le pousse donc là
on en est que je pense que je vais
enlever la première pièce c'est à dire
celle ci j'essaie de vous la faire voir
sent que ça bouge mon ensemble
celle-ci la halle est retenu que par lui
maintenant là donc on est bien d'accord
tout à l'heure c'était un hasard qu'on
est plus l'avancé mais je sais pas si
c'est la première pièce envisagée ou
s'il ya plusieurs pistes mais ça me va
mais là il n'ya plus que l qui retient
ça veut dire que si lui j'arrive à le
pousser et à le remonter
c'est vont donc pour le pousser et pour
le remonter pour trousser déjà
[Musique]
hahaha
maintenant ça marche pas mon truc
si ça marche ça marche ou pas oui oh
[ __ ] si c'est bon ça n'est pas le
monte fallu descendre nous avons on peut
mettre un bout des plaies deux mois je
vais signer ça je le mets jeudi j'ai
fini ex et les murs qu'est ce qu'on en
pense
mais il est intéressant de revenir là où
j'étais avant qui était quand même mieux
lui il faut pas grand chose pour qu'ils
puissent partir à temps c'est quoi qui
ne le bloque
pourquoi il est bloqué à il est bloqué à
cause de la cause de l'épée mais l'été
là si je sais pas encore si je la des
sangles et d'un livreur quand on les
voit encore un sens que je peux la
presse
oh là là vous souvenez ça on a déjà eu
je peux presque l'enlever lui je pense
que ce avec une excuse et loïc il a en
train de rouvrir le bureau parce qu'un
livreur et pourquoi comme ça en vrai
ouais
rappelle moi ce que tu m'as pris pour
moi je crois que c'est là bas tu connais
s'est passé dans harry potter c'est la
boisson qui boit pour réussir tout ce
qu'il entreprendra dans une journée
il est midi voici qu'est ce que le saint
graal
le felix felicis
le bouchon c'est mieux oui eh bien tu
m'expliquer pourquoi n'y a plus une
seule goutte de felix felicis j'en ai
pris en avance pour le montage de ces 15
heures de rechange moi je reste persuadé
qu'il faille baisser le lui mais du coup
pour le bc croient importants
excusez moi pour ma grosse tête et tout
ça mais à un moment donné faut que
j'arrive à réfléchir à la forme de
l'épée allait toujours pas bien clair
pour moi parce que c'est que sous l'épée
il ya un bout de bois mais c'est pas un
bout de bois droit ça fait des fous oui
voilà c'est beaucoup plus clair merci
loïc et du coup je comme je comprends
pas bien le dell dell de l'épée à
sillage là je la vois je peux pas vous
faire voir si en tout ou va bouger ça va
être relou mais je me dis mais je
regrette un peu un est embarqué
là-dedans
[Musique]
en vrai ça commence vraiment à me casser
la tête pour être vraiment très polis
est-ce qu'on serait pas une pause et je
fais un épisode 3 pour je m'engage
solennellement à enlever les dernières
pièces
ok ok je vous avoue jean peu plus de ma
vie le heat prépare un contrat
d'engagement de ma part je signe le
contrat ici contrat qui stipule que dans
la vidéo suivante je m'engage peu
importe le temps que ça prend à terminer
toutes les autres pièces mais on a quand
même une avancée certaine qui me donne
bon espoir pour la suite qui est le fait
que j'ai retiré une pièce aujourd'hui
mais là je vous avoue ça fait peut-être
six heures car un truc comme ça 6h20
second jeu jus clairement ma deuxième
les casse tête hein c'est pas le
problème me faites pas dire ce que je
n'ai pas dit mais j'en ai on est en fin
de vidéo on est entre gens n'est
vraiment pas envie de me coucher donc je
le reprends d'ici dix jours peut-être
une semaine ou dix jours laissez moi le
temps de le digérer quand même
il y aura d'autres vidéos entre temps de
trucs qu'on a tourné aussi qu'ils sont
pas forcément excalibur
je m'appelle donc fabien olicard je fais
des casse tête on sait pas pourquoi je
vous ai parlé de curieusement magazine
au début de la vidéo si vous voulez
avoir faites moi plaisir à défaire un
temps d'arrêt description juste pour
mater ce que c'est et pour voir ses
autres projets qui est hyper important
pour moi que j'adore en tout cas mettez
un pouce en l'air pour soutenir ses
abonnés vous activer la cloche pour pas
rater la suite
à très bientôt mais pas trompés ce soit
castex ciao